on to California now where the latest
round of storms that has battered that
state has now turned deadly a man was
killed when a tree fell into his van
just south of San Francisco the high
winds brought down the trees and the
wires throughout the Bay Area while
millions of people were under flood
watches Janet shamlian has more
[Applause]
looking like winds are
knocking down trees and forcing
pedestrians to Run for Cover
and nothing like I've ever seen before
here in San Francisco
across California Tuesday night almost
250 000 people were without power
wind gusts up to 80 miles per hour meet
one reporter's job almost impossible
on the San Francisco Oakland Bay Bridge
traffic was snarled for hours when a big
rig overturned the ground has become so
saturated a retaining wall on this
Northern California Interstate gave way
causing the road to set our designers
are looking at it right now our
Structural Engineers are looking at it
right now
meanwhile rain swollen streams are
washing out roads in Southern California
This SUV got carried 100 yards
Downstream after the driver got stuck
and managed to escape
torrential rain is also bearing down on
the area's hard hit Mountain communities
where it's expected to turn to snow as
temperatures drop we're just hoping that
it doesn't snow as much as it did last
time for CBS mornings I'm Janet shamlian
in Los Angeles